[Music]
sam is on the line in new york city sam
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys what's going on hey how are you
how can we help
you got i'm doing good uh basically my
dilemma is this i'm a senior in college
and um i'm majoring in business
management
they instituted a vaccine mandate and uh
they they denied my religious exemption
request
so what on that is you know i don't
graduate i was ready to graduate in may
so when that is now i transfer to a get
a random online degree
you know i feel like that's gonna affect
me
down the down the road what do you guys
think
okay so it's in business management is
what your degree's in
right okay where uh well tell me this
what is your concern about the online
just the fact that it's online that it
doesn't have some type of reputation
like the the school you went to or is it
this specific online school that you're
not just believing in as much
well yeah it just i mean i put in i
already invested so many years and so
much money to get this degree from you
know
and now to just go online
i just feel like it's not it's not the
same or am i overreacting
well i i just want to say i'm sorry that
happened um
i'm sorry you have put in the time and
now you're finishing out in a way that
you didn't want to
and i'm sorry because that's that
there's a little bit of of loss there to
grief you know like i thought it was
going to go this way and it didn't and
um and i hear that here's what i'll say
sam on my side of things of working for
this organization we hire a ton of
people i'm a certified business coach i
have hired plenty of people in my life
what people are looking for
has so much more
to do with
who you are
how you interview the skills that you
have the experience that you have then
the title on your degree i know you're
disappointed and i just want to say
that's valid i i can't you know i can't
blame you there just because you didn't
think it was going to go this way
i don't think it's going to keep you
from getting the job that you want i
think what's going to get you the job
that you want is you i think experience
networking doing what ken coleman
teaches getting around the people that
are doing what you want to do getting an
internship this year getting your foot
in the door building relationships
getting some experience solving problems
showing your skills developing your
skills helping people that's what's
going to get at your job that's what's
going to get you promotion it's not a
degree you're disappointed and i get
that but i just want to encourage you i
don't think that that's going to hold
you back
um i don't think that's what was going
to get you the job before and i don't
think it's going to keep you from
getting the job now i don't know george
what do you think i think it comes out
of the person yeah i've got questions
about your do your credits transfer i
mean how much are you losing here when
it comes to education
so i was going to graduate in may if i
transfer i have another year and a half
left it looks like
oh on top of that i didn't realize that
i thought it was the same track record
yeah just finishing you are losing a
good chunk of time by
switching to the online why
why
they don't they don't actually offer any
online it would be a different school
right but i'm saying can you find us i
was a transfer student i transferred
from university of central florida to
university of tennessee knoxville after
a year and a half and all but like four
credits transferred i found the school i
wanted to go to those in-state school to
get in-state tuition can you find an
online school that will accept the
majority of your credits where you're
only having to finish out maybe there's
a couple that don't transfer
that's my question got it
yeah so a part of it is because i spent
a year abroad
so this glam and counted that for credit
but a lot of these online um schools
aren't counting that towards credit my
year abroad that i spent and the school
isn't uh willing to let you finish out
online is there a way to do that
no yeah no they won't
interesting what school is this
system school of business okay
well i would do i would do some more
research and dig into it i don't want
you to just make this jump without
having all of the information possible
so now that you're going online i mean
the world is your oyster you can you can
do any program and a lot of these online
programs are actually really good now
you don't have to go with like a sketchy
online university you can find a lot of
accredited universities online with
online programs so i would call up every
single one that is an option that you
can cash flow and figure out who's going
to take the most credits so that you
spend the least amount of money and the
least amount of time to finish out this
degree yeah i didn't understand that sam
about adding so much time to your
education i totally agree i don't i
don't want you to do that either i'm
taking online classes right now through
fuller
seminary classes and i chose that to
your point george because i could choose
any school i wanted to because it's
online i was able to choose the one that
had the classes i wanted the program i
wanted so sam i think it might just take
some more research and digging to find a
school that's a better fit for your
specific program that might accept those
study abroad credits um that you can
customize and have less time yeah less
time don't add on all these
semesters if you don't have to in the
cost yeah i agree i think there's more
out there i think you might have to do
some digging to find it and i think
it'll be worth it if you do sam can you
cash flow this experience regardless
yeah
okay well that's good that's a that's a
big up right there so i think you need
to do some research and like christy
said sam is the determining factor here
not the degree the question is are you
good at business management and uh get
your feet in the door somewhere i mean i
started here as an intern and my degree
really was was not a huge part of that
discussion i started here as a project
manager so you and i both have stories
of starting out doing what we could
where we were yeah start with where you
are with what you got sam you got this
man this is the ramsay show